there are some people who like to just
show up and do a show and get a check
I'm interested in everything like when I
tour and they tell me hey we you're
doing the Chicago Theatre and here's how
much you're making and they can tell me
this big exciting number then I go I
asked them well how much do the tickets
and then they go well you know in order
to pay that they're charging 50 bucks
ticket I don't want people to pay 50
bucks a ticket to see me how much do I
get paid if they pay 30 bucks ticket
well geez it's only this I'm like well
that's more money than my dad made in
his life I'll take it and also I once I
started looking at that way I learned
stuff like I learned that if you ask for
a high guarantee for a live show you
drive up the ticket price cuz the risk
is higher but if you tell the theater
look don't guarantee me anything only
pay me if we if we make money then the
price of the tickets come down and they
don't have to advertise as much because
they're not as afraid that they're gonna
lose and if you work at a theatre
without a guarantee you actually get
paid more because the show cost less it
cost less for the the advertising all
that stuff and if you sell it out you
will make more money so I started
learning about that the story I tell on
Conan about the guy on next to me on the
airplane when the internet shuts down
suddenly I was really upset that the
internet shut down I was livid and then
I caught myself and said wait a minute
what are you what are you upset about
this was this was incredible that this
was possible even it was kind of like an
epiphany for me I started seeing things
differently like realizing that when we
get to a gate and they go we need ten
minutes because the plane that our gate
hasn't backed out yet and I go okay come
on like that was me let's go why it's
actually not gonna get me there quicker
I'm losing nothing I just feel bad but
if you can just like take a breath and
calm down and go yeah this is as good as
they make these right now this is as
good as it is and it's pretty goddamn
great
but somehow we part of me feels like if
people have to go back to basics a
little bit you just watched two amazing
clips from louis c.k take the next three
minutes to sit quietly and think about
how you can apply them to your business
and your life believe
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you